[Music]
New York Times declares war on YouTube
conservatives the paper accusing YouTube
stars of radicalizing people
The Times following the journey of caleb
kane a college dropout who clicked on
YouTube and as the piece put it was
steered court toward quote crazy town
here's Kane in his own words I was
depressed during that period of time and
looking for an outlet for that
depression and I turn to YouTube but
what I didn't realize was I was being
given a political philosophy and over
time my political idea started to change
quite drastically which was pretty you
know pretty clear to anybody in my life
at the time and really it just took me
into a place where I became further
isolated from social groups and just
started to ostracize a lot of people in
my life very unfairly here to respond
one of the personalities who The Times
accuses of radicalizing people Dave
Rubin the host of the Rubin Report now
I'm just nervous having you on Dave you
know yours you might radicalize me I
don't know what I'm getting into how do
you feel about being targeted this way
by the New York Times
yeah waters I hate to tell you you will
be a far-right all right radical by
talking to me a decent liberal that
tries to you know mend fences instead of
burning bridges like everybody else yeah
how did you get mixed with all these
people look first off just just right
atop I hate to actually bash the New
York Times because I come from a family
of New York liberals in the best sense
of that in the JFK sense of what liberal
means not sort of what the modern
progressive Democratic Party has become
so my dad who is still a liberal
Democrat to this day I mean he's
subscribed to the New York Times even
before I was born so 40-plus years so I
don't love the idea of coming on a bash
sometimes you got to put that side go
ahead you got to put that aside exactly
well look what happened was that my dad
sees this article in the Sunday Times
and it's not fun for your dad to have to
open up the newspaper and a couple pages
in see his son's picture with the words
all right underneath which is of course
the furthest for
the truth everything that I do on my
show is to fight the forces of
collectivism and racism and all of those
things now what the New York Times is
doing here I mean it's blatantly
disingenuous on its face because the
idea of the article was this kid who
basically started off as a lefty right
then he sort of became a conservative on
YouTube then he went down the alt-right
rabbit hole then they they sort of
implied that watching videos like mine
and this intellectual dark web that I'm
part of which is basically a group of
free thinkers that are trying to get
people to discuss certain issues
difficult issues to talk about we sort
of pulled him out of that and then he
ends up at the end of the article he
becomes a lefty he's a full-on lefty so
the premise of the article I mean that
YouTube is radicalizing people to the
far right except that the kid becomes a
lefty in here they radicalize them 360
degrees back where he started from you
know I don't like this because to me it
looks like the media is teaming up with
big tech and they're trying to slowly
chip away at influential thinkers and
personalities on social media and
because big tech is usually to the left
they get bullied by the media and they
get bullied by people on Twitter into
caving to just a few people that say
this is a bad guy this is a bad guy and
then we end up with less discussion and
debate but that's what they want they
want less to be oh yeah not only is that
what they want I mean that is what they
specifically are designing all of this
to do they do not like the fact that I
have a million-plus YouTube subscribers
and I treat conservatives decently
sometimes I agree with them sometimes I
don't but I treat you scary
conservatives like humans and that is
actually you can see what the New York
Times and CNN yeah pretty great guy what
do you say but that that's actually
against what the New York Times and The
Daily Beast and Vox and the rest of
these guys want to do and by the way
it's not like they give me any sort of
bonus for agreeing with them on certain
issues like a marriage or legalizing no
but the point you just made they want to
bully people into treating conservative
like aliens you're not allowed to talk
to them you can't mainstream them I mean
I know that you were gonna interview
Peabody judge on your show and Vaz
that's the same people that went after
steven crowder bullied Buddha judge and
did not do in your show but this were
just goes back to something that this
whole x thing was about radicalization
as far as i know this guy that was
looking at all your YouTube videos he
never shot anybody he never committed
any violence I don't see where the
radicalization is although you know a
couple years ago we saw a guy go online
and was looking at the Southern Poverty
Law Center and they you know list a
whole group of people that are anti-gay
the guy took a gun and shot up the
Family Research Council so I just don't
see very danger I'll give you the last
word well you know if you have a premise
if you're a journalist and I use that
word very loosely if you're a journalist
and you have a premise first you can
write almost any article to prove that
point but you know this guy's
radicalization not only does he end up
as a lefty the only other evidence they
use of his radicalization Jesse you're
not gonna believe this you know what he
did he baited a Christian woman oh wow
mystery woman that's right yeah that's
like an Isis bride according to the New
York Times you can't do that all right
Dave I got a run but thank you for
coming into waters world and thanks for
not radicalizing me too much I
appreciate it it's it's subtle my friend
all right look for the signs